miss Peter Bradley and I'm the executive
director or something
dlf is a member organization of large
research libraries along with the
Library of Congress National Archives
the British Library Oxford and we also
have some a line numbers such as icpsr
just scanned a few others so I just want
to use this brief time to try to talk
about some of the challenges that video
poses for digital libraries and in
essence this is really a dialogue for me
with the larger community is I struggle
to figure out the role of video in the
realm of digital library production and
distribution and engagement so my
thoughts here or extremely preliminary
in the really Metro spark of much longer
term conversations I actually want to
very briefly show if I can this nice
little video that some of you may have
seen but I just want to proselytize it
briefly this is from Stanford and it's
called a fairy use tail and it's a
mash-up of excerpts of Disney films of
designed to educate people about what
fair use is I won't let this run through
to completion but if you haven't seen it
I just want to introduce it to you very
briefly
if you can read the FBI warning it's
also a joke allow citizens to reproduce
distribute or exhibit portions of
copyrighted motion pictures
what the heck is coffee right what you
want the heck is copy copy it's that
long that's the problem you know the law
that stupid law what the heck is coffee
fight I'll tell you copy fight is a
permanently hoechst original mark what a
permanently hoechst the original walk in
in in some format can be seen or heard
hmm now listen this is important Oh lick
the copy right owner asked God right to
use their work it's mine how can that be
that's not fair it's forbidden to use a
copy right work without permission
granted by the copyright owner I'm sorry
buddy who's foolish enough to threaten
our coffee right has broken the law
aren't we forgetting one teensy-weensy
but ever so crucial did for tiny detail
you'd better be able to pay for that
coffee fight permission we haven't
discussed the subject of payment you
can't get something for nothing you know
but I don't have I'm not asking mouth
just a token way via trifle hold on
bagger are you saying this is about
money I'm sorry sir I don't have any
money successfully I prefer the term
capitalist hear that sound it's the
sound of your freedom fluttering out the
window okay I'll stop back there so I
encourage you to see the rest of this
video because it continues in the same
theme
so it's a cinder for new media at
Stanford if you do a search for very use
tail then we'll be able to find it I
think it's like many of these things
quite viral right now on the net so I
expect it will be a very widely
distributed video and and will
distribute the URL to the community here
so anyway I want to get back on the talk
and stream through the rest of my slides
you know with as the world changes I
struggle a lot is too many of my
colleagues with trying to redefine what
does a library actually do because
historically what we've done is we've
bought books and then we've distributed
them and so we have to sort of rethink
our mission and how we engage our
community my friend and the publishing
industry Mike Schadt skin it has pinned
this in the context are actually have
changes in publishing of what value is a
repository printed content in a world
where everything is just covered in
available through the computer the
answer is not nearly as much as it is
today as as today and not a fraction of
what it was 20 years ago so when I think
about video I think about the challenges
that libraries have beginning to even
put their heads around what it means to
work with new media this is a picture of
a marvelous beautiful new library at
Berkeley where I have my office it's
their new music library and even this I
find an interesting concept in a digital
age what exactly is a music library in
an in an era of itunes I mean obviously
their CDs that people can listen to but
part of the genesis of any music
libraries actually to have text about
music but when you go into the music
library you seem not that really many
bulks on music actually on this library
has an amazing amount of underutilized
space and I think it was built at a time
of transition and it's one of the first
libraries I've seen that I think
unfortunately captures that transit
in its physical space utilization
because they're not going to be able to
fill the space easily with books on
music and I think the way that they
anticipated nor will the space
consumption be utilized by physical
media so libraries have been all about
physical things we've had the books
music has been records or CDs and video
has been tape or DVDs and we've rented
these things out to people to see at
stations and then they've consumed them
and brought them back and and then we do
that again it's a very obviously
non-digital way of distributing
information so library is in essence
have been offline not on the network
despite the fact that we can find things
in the library on the network really a
lot of the use of libraries has been
offline in a really profound way the
attitude of libraries has basically been
we've got a lot of really interesting
content that we've either purchased or
licensed to make available to our
community please come and use it it's a
very passive definition of what a
library is it's assuming that users can
find information that's associated with
the library and then come to the library
usually physically in order to utilize
that content but as peter has said
obviously the world has changed
significantly and people can now build
and create their own content their own
video their own audio in their own text
they make their own media in a way that
I think librarians just have not fully
understood yet I don't think that
there's a sense or an understanding of
the shift in production styles this is a
sticky on a post outside of Berkeley
make media make trouble at the indeed
independent media org side from San
Francisco so you know this attitude of
and this ability of making media I think
really obviously is a portent of a
revolute
that spells trouble for libraries in an
interesting and challenging way what's a
library to do in this kind of
environment where the ability to produce
content has been democratized the
ability to access content is assumed
also to be widely distributed and very
democratized as well so one thing that
libraries have done is they've become
cafes and they serve coffee and tea and
cookies and muffins I love this shot
this is actually at one of the Berkeley
libraries which free speech movement
cafe at Berkeley and you'll see the
video screen on the background and
everybody has their laptop open with
your notes spread and you know I think
also another really interesting thing
about this shot is that you see people
working together in a very collaborative
fashion you know this is much less even
as they've got their laptops popped up
you know head to head you know they're
talking over them this is not the
solitary person reading the thick tome
in the corner of the library model that
I think you know I grew up with anyway
but you know these new media have
challenges because they're ephemeral
music is sound video is movement neither
is a stain in the way that they've
printed book was a thing that could be
held and distributed and catalogued and
circulated so the question for me is how
can a library be an active participant
in this engagement how does a library go
about making things from the content
that it has and from the content that it
can access through the contributions of
its own membership its own community
students faculty staff in the broader
use community that library serve because
video shouldn't obviously be passively
consumed video I strongly believe can
teach in a way that text never can video
and live events conversation and
enlivens education in really critical
and important ways that I think
libraries in research universities must
grapple with a fundamental ago
Eve that library should deeply engage in
understanding how to utilize video
resources to provide educational
enrichment for students for faculty in
ways that have never been explored
before this is obviously a picture of a
surveillance camera a park outside of
the UC Berkeley mathematics library on
the bottom floors building where I work
obviously this is not quite the same
kind of video experience that I'm
suggesting libraries explore with their
user community so video is didactic
video in our new world of being able to
produce content easily is an exchange
it's not just a consumption and again I
think this is an area where libraries
have not really been able to understand
fully the revolution that's taken place
here because there's a conversation and
libraries need to be part of that
conversation universities need to be
part of that conversation with their
students it's not a one-way street we
need to really understand that there's a
conversation going back and forth
between our faculty our students in the
institution itself libraries I think can
tell incredible stories with the
resources that are available to them
libraries are full of staff who have
incredible intuition about content about
data description about how to utilize
information and really that that
expertise is going to some extent wasted
and video and audio so I think a new
library is about partnering in a much
deeper way than we've done before with
scholars and information technologists
and people who are engaging themselves
in the creation of media to build new
ways of getting information available to
our community and available for reuse so
that's a library that's on the network
in a way that we haven't been before not
offline in a sense of find the stuff and
then come to us but engage delivering
distributing making content available
we're half of the way there in some ways
libraries have and are preserving a
tremendous amount of highly valued video
resources tremendously wonderful stuff
and beginning to explore with making
this content available for annotation
and for consumption and reuse by faculty
but we need to struggle more with
understanding how to make it available
in libraries desperately need partners
from the outside community to advise us
on how to go about utilizing this
information and making it available for
broader a consumption and that would be
you I hope thank you very much